you probably recognize Benjamin Joseph
madellaine Novak known professionally as
BJ Novak as Ryan from NBC's the office
or maybe you recognize him from one of
his many TV or movie appearances either
way though
you probably don't recognize him from
anything recent because when it comes to
acting he seems to have disappeared
here's a look at why Hollywood won't
cast BJ Novak anymore he was never a
leading man before becoming an actor
Novak made a name for himself as a
stand-up comedian performing on Late
Night with Conan O'Brien and Comedy
Central's premium blend in 2003 variety
named him one of it's ten comics to
watch thanks in part to his gigas Ashton
Kutcher's sidekick on MTV celebrity
prank show Punk'd and when he did break
into acting it was in supporting roles
besides the office Novak is probably
best known for his small roles and
inglorious basterds and the amazing
spider-man 2 as well as cameos and
numerous TV shows but despite his
success Novak never became a leading man
in part because he was busy with other
interests off-camera well back to the
old ecstasy Factory major breakthrough
shortly after getting his big break on
Punk'd Novak caught the attention of the
office executive producer Greg Daniels
with a joke that would change his life
forever I learned nothing in college it
was really kind of my own fault I had a
double major psychology and reverse
psychology Daniels told the Boston Globe
he knew immediately after hearing it he
wanted to work with Novak besides
playing temp Ryan Howard Novak became
more and more involved behind the scenes
ultimately writing and producing
numerous episodes and when his longtime
friend and office co-star Mindy Kaling
left to develop her own series the Mindy
project Novak took a job as one of the
show's producers leaving little time for
acting success is an author in 2013
Novak signed a seven-figure book deal
would not Doubleday Publishing Group
around the same time his short story the
man who invented the calendar appeared
in The New Yorker his first book a
collection of short stories called one
more thing was released in 2014 and
received critical praise for its
intelligent satire and tender heart
Novak hasn't just found success with an
adult audience however he also penned
the best-selling children's book the
book would
no pictures a strange prospect for young
readers Novak told the Guardian I wanted
to write a book that would introduce the
youngest of kids to the idea that words
can be their allies that the right words
can be fun exciting and ridiculous as
any pictures also I can't draw he wants
to direct after playing a supporting
role in Quentin Tarantino's satirical
war film Inglourious Basterds Novak
realized that in addition to writing and
producing he's also interested in
directing he told the independent after
I acted in this film I knew I wanted to
direct it feels like a natural extension
to take something you've created all the
way to the finishing line that's why I
visit schools now with my children's
phone I get real joy when I take my work
directly to the reader thanks to the
office and the Mindy project Novak had a
chance to get his feet wet directing
several episodes I feel like there's a
voice in my head always telling me every
ideas brilliant and another telling me
every idea is the worst and they argue
in my head he also made an app in 2015
Novak developed an app called
the list app which allowed users to well
make a list it sounds simple enough but
it proved to be a hit lasting for two
years before Novak shut it down in order
to begin developing a new app so keep
your eyes peeled a future in politics
when he was young Novak actually wanted
to be a real estate developer he told
The Guardian I think I had some vague
awareness of Donald Trump like I want to
put my name on buildings I want to be
rich and important in the businessman so
it's only fitting that he now wants to
follow Trump's lead by transitioning
from TV star to politician but he
doesn't want to be President he wants to
become the mayor of Los Angeles he told
the independent I'm not hugely political
I just love my town I'm from Boston but
I live in the Hollywood Hills I've come
to love the local side of LA much more
than the Hollywood sign I have dreams of
running for mayor someday given how
successful he has been with everything
else he's tried we sure wouldn't put it
past
good luck mayor Novak thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you
[Music]